utilizing a hundred and eighty-seven
rolls of duct tape to make 2,000 feet of
rope and a canopy of 500 square feet
it's been a monumental undertaking
Buster's up the ground and this is the
moment of truth
will that duct-tape parachute they're a
save your life too
incredibly buster looks like he's going
to make it the duct tape parachute is
working
Oh No
now it's ugly
we just did our duct-tape parachute test
and man giving questions arrived no I
thought he was either gonna go perfectly
or horribly and both things happen I'm
not getting a pulse so I want to confirm
on that last drop that Buster died he
landed at about 28 miles per hour which
is equivalent to falling out of a fourth
or fifth story window some people in
history have survived such a drop most
don't
but that drop did yield one piece of
very compelling data and that is once
the chute opened and it was successfully
open even though it was for a brief
period of time the speed at which Buster
was descending was 13 miles per hour
precisely the number that Valerie's math
said he should be falling at I wish I
could do it again actually there's no
reason that we can't do it again you
guys want to go for another run yes
excellent this might actually work I
gotta tell you I'm a little surprised